in the Indian
Ocean another mom has to time her
journey to
Perfection on a tiny Speck of land
Monsoon
rains trigger a miracle
of
nature she may not look that
impressive but this little Christmas
Island red crab around the size of your
hand is on a mission to become a
mom
crabs evolved in the
sea but she's completely adapted to a
life on
land
almost her babies will only develop in
saltwater but to get there a fem Trek
from her home in the
forest all the way
down to the
beach it's a long way on 4in
legs especially walking
sideways at least she's got
Comfort 70 million milon moms and dads
to be called back to the ocean once a
year to
[Music]
breed this big little journey can take
two
weeks and on the way
there will be
casualties 10 times her
size the largest land crab on
Earth robber
crab armed with crustacean crushing
Pincers
the red crabs eyesight so bad that it's
easy to run into
trouble and harder to get out Al
alive and less luck is on your
side
but there are bigger dangers still to
[Music]
face she's got to time
this just
right
fortunately on lots of roads here
today the crabs get the right of way
a million strong
March all
arrive right on
schedule at the
[Music]
beach